perhaps unsurprisingly complaints about
rail operators also sort last year up by
nearly a third to two million and twenty
percent of customers one in five say
they're resigned to a poor service
that's worse than any other sector
meanwhile complaints against all the UK
companies rose from 52 million to 55
million during 2016
those figures were compiled by the
Ombudsman services they provide
independence dispute resolution for a
number of financial and economic sectors
Lewis and Smith is the chief Ombudsman
and he's here in the studio with me I
mean quite shocking numbers there are a
lot of people dissatisfied with the
services they're getting a lot of people
making complaints yeah much higher much
higher than last year and interestingly
people are much more willing to complain
than they were before the study we've
done shows that people are something
like 26 percent more likely to complain
than they were this time last year and I
want to show you I've got a couple of
things to show you in our screens here
one of which just shows you those
different sectors so parts of the
economy where people say they are just
not satisfied and rail being the main
one about 1 in 5 kind of 20 percent of
people think rail service you don't
cover rail services do you at the moment
there's no Ombudsman that covers rail
services and I know that the
government's looking very closely as is
the industry itself trying to put
something in place that will give people
a means to make complaints and have
those complaints had independently okay
but let's okay let's rewind what is the
point of Auburn batsman's services I
mean we're seeing that people are
complaining but they're not actually
kind of converting those complaints
through to the Ombudsman any you know
five percent a few years ago maybe up a
bit since then are actually complaining
to the Ombudsman yeah when the Ombudsman
for the energy industry in the
communications industry in the UK we
have seen a rise and complaints coming
through to us what what our role is that
is when when you've complained to a
company and you remain dissatisfied or
the company's just not answered you once
eight weeks have passed you have a legal
right to come to us we've take the
complaint we'll look at it from both
sides because we are independent make a
decision and if the customer accepts
that decision it's legally binding and
so last year I think we did about 80,000
80,000 investigations and total okay
it takes a while doesn't it and is there
a problem there that people are you know
finding that process of having to go to
the Ombudsman's so you know it's gonna
take such a long time it's so demanding
that they just don't do it
they think it's demanding they think it
will take a long time but actually it
doesn't it's quite easy to maximum 42
days the the target they're talking
we're sort of fella and you need to wait
no no no you can do it quite easily
online you can do it by phone we'll fill
in the form for you it's free to use
it's easy to use we'll keep you updated
as Prague as we progress and as I say at
the end of it you may get back what you
think you're old or you will get back if
you're doing because if you think if you
think you don't say a hundred planes by
your energy supplier why not go and get
it just I mean it bounced the EU
referendum some of these Ombudsman
services are kind of supported by EU
legislation the rules particularly for
consumer Ombudsman you know is there a
risk that coming out of the EU will
remove some of those protections for the
UK I don't think it will because the the
government is very clear and it's it's
it's aimed to give more protection to
consumers not less protection to
consumers the Chancellor said that in
his autumn statement and I think we'll
see that developing in the green the
green paper comes out this year so I
think we'll actually see the government
doing the opposite it's very keen to see
an increase in consumer protection